yesterday was the one year anniversary
of the january 6 trump riots joe biden
the president spoke to the country
yesterday morning and it was without
question the best speech joe biden has
ever given now whether you think that
there was a low standard or a high
standard for that it doesn't really
matter it was by far the best speech
that he has given as president the
energy the fire
where has it been until now almost like
a completely different biden and we're
going to look at the speech the speech
was immediately called divisive by fox
news which to me means joe biden did a
really good job of placing blame for the
january 6 riots of 2021 exactly where
they belong at the feet of donald trump
to a great degree
let's just jump right into the first
segment
what did we not see
we didn't see a former president
who had just rallied the mob to attack
sitting in the private dining room off
the oval office in the white house
watching it all on television right and
doing nothing
for hours
as police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital under siege
this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed insurrection
they weren't looking to uphold the will
of the people they were looking to deny
the will of the people true they were
looking uphold they weren't looking
uphold a free and fair election they
were looking to overturn one
they were looking to save
the cause of america
they were looking to subvert the
constitution
this isn't about being bogged down in
the past
it's about making sure the past isn't
buried
that's the only way forward
that's what great nations do
they don't bury the truth
they face up to it sounds like hyperbole
but that's the truth they face up to it
we are a great nation
my fellow americans
in life there's truth
and tragically there are lies
lies conceived and spread
for profit
and power
we must be absolutely clear about what
is true
and what is a lie
and here's the truth
the former president of the united
states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
is more important than his country's
interest than america's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution
he can't accept he lost
very very well said and we'll look at a
couple of other moments here joe biden
saying
are we going to be a country that
accepts political violence
or are we going to be a country that
rejects that which is the fundamental
question when we think back to these
riots
and so at this moment
we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
these are the fundamental questions one
year in and the reason that they're
fundamental as much as right-wingers
want to say
the left is making such a big deal like
people like ben shapiro were saying the
riots were bad but the people who did it
have been punished it wasn't an
insurrection there was no chance it was
going to steal an election well the
question is what will happen in 2022
what will happen in 2024 what if the
generals that wrote the retired generals
who wrote that up that i talked about on
monday saying
if the military were on the side of the
coup
it actually could happen what about that
and joe biden also during the speech
laying out what it was that happened on
january 6th phony partisan audits were
undertaken
long after the election in several
states
none
changed the results
and in some of them the irony is the
margin of victory actually grew slightly
so let's speak plainly about what
happened in 2020
even before the first ballot was cast
the former president was preemptively
showing doubt about the election results
true
he built his lie over months
wasn't basing any facts
he was just looking for an excuse a
pretext
to cover for the truth
he's not just a former president
he's a defeated former president
and we will actually talk about trump's
reaction to this a little bit later but
first we are just following the joe
biden speech
joe biden pointing out something i've
been talking about for years which is
you know these people's stated
principles
which they abandon as soon as they're
inconvenient
the same applies to the law says joe
biden you can't just abide in the law
when you don't like it
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient
you can't be patriotic when you embrace
and enable lies
those who storm this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of america
at american democracy
the best speech i have seen joe biden
give as president and here he is uh just
winding it down this is the last clip
we'll look at and listen to authority in
this nation will always
be peacefully transferred
i believe the power of the presidency
and the purpose is to unite this nation
not divide it so lift us up
not tear us apart
it's about us
about us
not about me
deep in the heart of america burns
aflame lived almost 250 years ago
of liberty freedom and equality
this is not a land of kings or dictators
or autocrats
we're a nation of laws of order not
chaos of peace not
violence here in america the people rule
through the ballot
and their will prevails
so let us remember together
we're one nation
under god
indivisible
that today
tomorrow
and forever at our best we are the
united states of america so joe biden
ending the speech as he often does but a
very very good speech
the right calling it divisive the right
saying it was not a uniting speech and
it is all typical of the right
to say that calling out the divisive
actions of a year ago is divisive seeing
racism is racist this is the same trope
that they've been pulling for a while
very nicely done by joe biden doesn't
change anything about his effectiveness
as a legislator
or getting getting legislation passed
but this was a very good speech and part
of the reason you know it was good is it
so triggered the former president donald
trump
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video